hey uh the chaos continues within the
Trump campaign I told you last week that
after replacing fired campaign manager
Corey Lewandowski with Russian connected
Paul Manafort as campaign manager then
Paul Manafort was replaced by Republican
strategist Kellyanne Conway and the CEO
of Breitbart news Steve Bannon it was
plain to see that mana fort was
effectively out the official line was oh
he's not the campaign manager what is
the campaign chairman he's overseeing
everything it was totally campaign
optics BS and it lasted a few days now
Donald Trump campaign chairman and
former campaign manager Paul Manafort
has resigned clearly he was fired and
told you have to resign everything about
mana for its involvement in the Trump
campaign has been a disaster we found
out about this history of working for
Pro Russian Ukrainian politician Viktor
Yanukovych we had the reports about this
handwritten ledger which listed man
afford in his associates as being owed
or receiving 12.7 million dollars in
under-the-table payments we found out
that mana fort played a really key role
in pretty in fomenting these Pro
annexation sentiments in Crimea and here
is the statement from the Trump campaign
from Donald Trump about the resignation
quote of of a Paul Manafort this morning
Paul Manafort offered and I accepted his
resignation from the campaign it's good
already I am very appreciative for his
great work in helping to get us where we
are today and in particular his work
guiding us through the delegate and
convention process yet real guide Paul
is a true professional and I wish him
the greatest success uh the Russia thing
was not a non-factor Politico said that
trumps family was very troubled by the
constant report reports of mana Ford's
connection to Russia and as usual even
within the Trump campaign people were
reportedly surprised by this no internal
communication whatsoever same as when
Corey Lewandowski was fired and here's
Eric trump donald trump son on fox news
there is no language here that suggests
this was man affords idea that it's
abundantly clear that Trump fired this
guy take a look I think my father didn't
want to be you know distracted by you
know whatever things
yup always was dealing with in Nepal was
amazing India you know he helped us get
through the primary process he helped us
get to the convention he did a great job
with with the delegates yeah uh you know
and uh you know now you look at am
Telling in some the other people that
were bringing in and they're absolutely
fantastic and I think they're gonna be
the ones that bring us you know all the
way through november eighth and
ultimately get us that the victory but
again my father just in one have that
the distraction looming over the
campaign in quite frankly looming over
all the issues that that Hillary's
facing yeah if the if the story line is
is manna for resigned to Jason you don't
have your kid go on Fox News and explain
why Trump didn't want him around because
that narrative immediately falls apart
yeah i think is more narrative a really
good you know professional amazing
comedy movie that yet is this the job
that they're trying to set themselves up
for the resume you know Trump if Eric
trump is like mini Trump right saying
Paul Manafort was amazing and we're
bringing in terrific people it's just
it's mirroring everything Trump does
none of these people are terrific but
yes he mirrors Trump in just about every
way except for using words his word his
word is a slightly different I don't
think he said terrific right uh yeah I
did he now I'm not sure it was amazing I
me he definitely amazing I thought he
said terrific are fantastic in normal
circumstances firing to campaign
managers in under two months would be
sort of a problem for your campaign it's
not even on the top five list of
problems for the Trump campaign in the
last week because it's so insane over
there but they are doing a good job at
not making it seem at hiding the fact
that the campaign is in total disarray
are they it seems pretty clear what
might seem clear to us but I mean they
they're still operating as normal and
and they still have a great deal of
support across the country great deal
well yeah I mean before there's now one
poll of the last twenty-four where Trump
has any lead and it's a one-point lead
statistically a tie so uh something is
happening here and we've got to figure
out to quote the great Donald Trump what
the hell is going on we'll take a break
and be back after this Warby Parker is
offering a free five day home try-on to
give you the opportunity to check out
their glasses i personally wear Warby
Parker glasses when I'm not wearing my
contact lenses and I also started with
one of these free at home
try ons of five pairs of glasses you can
get your free home try-on and support
the david pakman show at Warby Parker
trial dot-com / TDPS I don't really like
going into glasses stores and trying on
glasses well the salesperson sort of
hovers over me and I like more than 30
seconds to actually figure out whether I
like the glasses so with the Warby
Parker home try-on I was able to pick
five pairs that i liked put them on in
the comfort of my own home pick the one
I like the most and then Warby Parker
put my prescription lenses in there for
me a lot of people don't know that the
eyeglass industry is controlled by just
a few big corporations that keep prices
very high like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold Warby Parker distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need you
can try five pairs and see what you like
check out the at-home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker
dot-com / TDPS it costs nothing